it started with a weird piercing sound
it was persistent high-pitched
high-pitched sound very very
loud those who heard that told
newspapers it was soon followed by
strong nausea an incredible case of
vertigo dizziness excruciating headaches
these mysterious afflictions were first
reported in the cuban capital in 2016.
and there were thus called havana
syndrome havana syndrome havana syndrome
since then more cases have been reported
in china
vienna
and now also berlin
the symptoms were described as an
invisible injury many victims reported
brain damage without ever sustaining a
concussion
what's even stranger is that of about
200 reported cases nearly half involved
cia agents
that's why these incidents started to
look a lot like sonic attacks attack of
unknown nature with a mysterious
invisible weapon
conjectures abounded the investigations
that followed focused on sonic weapons
energy devices and secret microwave
beams
but while speculation like this bends
the limits of what's physically possible
some scientists are putting forward a
rather unremarkable explanation that has
been remarkably overlooked
the line of demarcation in the cold war
lies in berlin berlin has long been a
city of spies
[Music]
during the cold war it was the closest
contact point between the east and the
west a city where soviets and nato
powers were constantly spying on each
other from the other side of the berlin
wall
[Music]
today some experts think the city could
once again become a hotbed of espionage
and they point to a familiar suspect
russia
[Music]
berlin recently reported two cases of
havana syndrome
both victims were us officers working on
cases linked to russia
one on the controversial nordstrom 2
pipeline
the other one on russian cyber attacks
but why would anyone think russians are
using microwave beams
well maybe because they've done it
before
from 1953 to 1976 russia bathed the u.s
embassy in moscow with microwaves
u.s intelligence called it the moscow
signal
microwaves have also already been used
as a weapon
the so-called active denial system
developed by the us uses wave energy to
disperse crowds
you might have seen clips of drones
taken down using similar technology
oh and remember that ticking sound
microwaves can produce audible clicks
too this is called the fray effect
if you put it all together the image of
russian spy is using new energy weapons
seems pretty plausible right
we could speculate about little green
men you know throwing lightning bolts
down these people my name is kenneth
foster foscer i'm a professor emeritus
at the university of pennsylvania
um in biomedical engineering i have like
maybe at this point a 50-year interest
in the subject
as well as being having done some of the
original research on this effect you
have to have evidence to draw
conclusions and there was none
[Music]
the first problem is that a microwave
weapon would be difficult to hide
no you're talking about something the
size of a big shipping container
the antennas are probably three meters
across
the beam would also leave clear evidence
it caused major interference problems
and it's hard to focus the energy in a
small beam and the field strength is so
large that it would burn out wi-fi sets
and reset computers
oh and that's strange sound
the classified investigation suggests it
was likely
caribbean
crickets as this theory loses
credibility some scientists are asking
us to consider one that's even more
uncomfortable
functional disorders are incredibly
common actually there's a second
commonest reason to see a neurologist
and the commonest reason to see a
gastroenterologist and yet it's
incredibly hidden
enter john stone one of 38 prominent
neurologists psychologists and
psychiatrists who wrote an open letter
suggesting that these symptoms could be
best explained as a kind of functional
disorder
harvard medical school defines them as a
condition with symptoms that no physical
examination or testing can explain the
condition is considered to be a mental
disorder but it results in very real
physical ailments so for example
irritable bowel syndrome
or fibromyalgia and many other forms of
chronic pain
are types of functional disorder
they do have their basis in the body
they're not just all in the mind that
these things are actually happening
[Music]
given the lack of clarity over how
functional disorders arise
patients often encounter skepticism when
talking about them
at times they have been described as a
form of hysteria compounding stigmas
around them
there is that characterization of
functional disorders as
these are conditions affected by work
shy people or people with mental illness
it's just not the case anyone can be
affected by a functional disorder
including cia agents
dizziness headaches nausea
are all typical symptoms of functional
disorders when i read about these
patients i thought well these are
patients that are typical of patients i
would see on a monday morning in my
clinic
but the similarities don't stop here
nearly all types of brain injury are
worst at the beginning because that's
when the brain's just been injured
and then slowly improve over time
but with the havana syndrome symptoms
typically worsen over time
what we see in functional disorders is
very often that
patients have a minor physical event
it does give them symptoms but then it
sets in train a set of symptoms which
kind of worsen each other so you have
dizziness because then you can't sleep
and the more you can't sleep the more
tired you get and then other symptoms
come along
exceptional stress can also trigger
these disorders if your boss at work
tells you there might be a sonic weapon
around then you might start to interpret
things that are actually perhaps normal
initially as a problem
the jury is still out on what caused
these symptoms
other experts disagree that they were
caused by functional disorders perhaps
it was a combination of factors perhaps
something completely different i've not
met these patients and it's really
important that i'm i'm not sitting here
saying i know what's wrong with these
people because that's not good medicine
what's certain is that the pain these
people are going through is very real
the distinction between psychological
and physical pain
much less so
[Music]
these are common disabling
distressing conditions that can affect
anybody
from any walk of life
and why is it that we are dismissing
them with incredibly stereotyped and
stigmatized views that doesn't make any
sense to me we should be considering
them seriously
and thinking about more ordinary
explanations for illnesses perhaps
before
extraordinary ones